back to what we're saying with this this
pocahontas [ __ ] right so it just came
out that this woman who was like the
leader of like the [ __ ] native
american health board or something like
that in canada um barossa i think is her
name yeah she just came out as a
complete fraud she's not even native
american she's like polish russian and
something else incredibly white like the
whitest white she's looking native of
america she's pulling it off though
i asked him i imagine native americans
look like native americans i'm sorry but
that's what y'all look like to us
yeah
okay it is true okay so she's out here
got the whole garb on i mean yeah really
doing it yeah and then
again yeah she looks like the guy in
marvel that like they make like the
holes they go like this dr strange
yeah you know the [ __ ] doctor
strange and the asian dude they go like
this yeah and it's like a little portal
yeah yeah i love that fat asian guy
i tried to watch shang chi that's
another one i watched how was that oh
ronnie chang's in there yeah ronnie's
great i literally just turned around
because ronnie said yeah i got past
ronnie's part and i was like i'm good
yeah you're the king of trying [ __ ]
we're talking about that before you're
just trying hey good for you you tried
you're trisexual though you're trisexual
i'm trying
i'll try anything diy sexual can we just
invent a thing for white people so they
can opt out of whiteness of white
responsibility yeah let's just invent a
thing yeah bisexuality we did but they
actually got to do something non-binary
non-binary yeah yeah because that's
saying i'm not a man or a woman i use
they them pronouns but it's so cocky
yeah but then you're part of the group
like if you're already a cuck if you
want no accountability like you live
this much better i don't know if it's
much better but you live a better life
because you're white and the second you
have to deal with any accountability
because of that you're like well i'm not
actually i'm part of the lgbt community
yeah yeah are you are you when you walk
into the bodega and you don't get
followed around you're a struggle
appropriator
you appropriate struggle
you don't like appropriation don't
appropriate our struggle interesting
these people are so dumb you can just
flip all their own [ __ ] on them that's
good it's all just a little bit of
gymnastics that's all you gotta do
anytime they're offended if you just
throw out the word privilege that it's
like a [ __ ] landmine they can't touch
but but you're 100 right about that if
they're being honest with themselves but
they're not being honest with themselves
no right and because they're not they
actually truly start to believe these
things yeah it's the same thing with
going to outer space yeah it's the same
sociopathy right it's like i truly want
to save humanity yeah by doing my little
pet project yes right no you don't you
just need a convenient reason to spend
billions of dollars while people are
starving to death yeah right and yeah
you're allowed to do that you made the
billions of dollars yeah you know what i
mean like do whatever you want you're
saving this is the same thing yes they
need that goal you need a justification
for your own i don't want to be
accountable so i'm going to force myself
to believe i'm oppressed too i don't
identify with any gender
who die who does we need to make a test
for it okay we do like like an
ancestry.com
but if you're non-binary you're gay so
that's what
that like we need to check like are you
actually that do you have gayness in
your face is it twenty percent are you
50 or are you just making it up like
pocahontas yeah i think that's what
ancestry.com is too 23andme all that
stuff oh yeah how do i opt out of
whiteness yeah of course but we gotta do
that for forever everything twenty three
twenty three and i don't believe any of
their results i think they just throw in
a little minority for everybody a little
black a little indian buddies ten
percent or two percent african or
whatever it is it's like ain't we a
hundred percent like how far back does
this go yeah if if this [ __ ] goes to our
roots it should all be african right if
that's what humanity started yeah how
does it know when to start and how does
it know to go back only a couple hundred
years yeah if it goes back one
generation you're american how does it
know how many generations to go back
this test is cap yeah
and it is like how does it know when to
go back yep
if you trace it all back aren't we all
related
we're all just [ __ ] our cousins yes
yeah yeah 100 percent because we're
interested out here that's fire that
porn category should be way more broad
yeah we're sesting dogs
you never say that while having sex huh
you never say that like dirty talking
like yo you like that cuz you like that
you know where to say that
she's like what isis
yeah yeah you're my cousin
[Laughter]
yeah i don't uh we have the video of the
uh native american girl talking
yeah it's so funny
yeah so can you explain what this is so
basically she's giving her tedx talk in
saskatchewan tedx is fire bro tedx is so
funny dude tedx background check first
of all not easy to get a tedx yeah did
you get relaxed i got did a tedx and
it's so easy the producer of the thing
was the guy who produced uh four four
one
production said hey we're producing a
thing do you want to like give a talk
fire and i'm sure they saw maybe like
you were popping off at the time yeah
this guy got some [ __ ] going on but at
the same time they're just like yeah
we'll just put you on yeah so there's no
rhyme or reason no i should happen to
blow up because i was derogan and then
people found it but there's been a
couple like there was one tedx i saw
where this dude like dressed as like a
knight
and he was like talking about like
medieval [ __ ] like walking around like
in the full night costume just like
making up stuff and i was like what is
this
like when ted first came out i believed
everything they said and then certain
people started getting ted talks and i
was like oh we're just having fun yeah
we're just having fun
who got it that you stopped believing it
besides me
that was the moment
i got friends with like [ __ ] 4 000
followers on instagram and they're just
like in a master's program and i'm like
okay you're not i i know you yeah you
don't do anything
there's no innovation here yeah good for
you i'm gonna watch the speech because i
support you but i'm not gonna listen to
the [ __ ] the og was just a ted talk and
then tedx was like the answer would be
like more localized and that's the
satellite school yeah that's when you do
harvard online
that's harvard
come on man it's a spin-off dude who
wants it to have a spin-off cheers have
fraser ted got tedx yeah there you go
yeah yeah but i got i got numbers yeah
where's your ted talk though yeah
talking all that [ __ ] i'm waiting for
the big ted
teddy
okay so let's listen to this line ass
[ __ ] now i will clarify what she said
is later when they called her out and
some of her colleagues called her out
yeah uh yeah haters doing all this work
to help native americans [ __ ] native
americans they're like no we don't want
your help that's the [ __ ] i do not get
if she was using it to like do ads for
[ __ ] american apparel or something
like that probably not the right
surprise
but you know
yeah
[Laughter]
but like if she was like doing and
profiting off and doing [ __ ] buffalo
gap ads like she was really profiting
off of this identity she was doing like
movies and stuff like that but she is a
[ __ ] government job sense where she's
trying to help native americans and if
you know she's a fraud shut your mouth
also she's in canada right it's first
nations she said oh whatever first
nations come on bro come on can't be
disrespecting these i don't even know
that's first
what are y'all first of all
i was actually what are your first
that y'all foreign to leave a nation to
cross the ice bridge to even start your
first nation you're not even close to
first you were one of the last nations
also one of the tribes might have killed
the actual first nations yeah so they
might be second or third
oh nations
that's a better point you know what i
mean
that's a better point i was trying to
follow that one but i wasn't there that
one makes sense but my point that i'm
trying to make is
there were nations that existed before
yeah but they're not saying to the first
nation they're saying the first in the
nation they're the first people on this
nation
no they're saying they're first nations
they're saying these are the first
nations here but i'm clarify fam don't
be out here first nation yeah okay do
you know what i mean all right it's like
it's that's like when white people put
cornrows on the cover of vogue like a
new trend
okay they're called that's what they did
they're they're called
kardashians native americans yeah i was
talking about it before i was like i
think it's kind of foul that like we
call native americans americans but if
anybody could do cornrows it's gotta be
native americans right that's their [ __ ]
yeah but people are kind of
appropriating the cornrow from native
american okay are we gonna watch this
my name is morning star bear
my name is morning star bear i'm just
gonna say it i'm emotional so
uh
very good
i'm bear clan i'm an anishinabe metis
from treaty 4 territory and i want to
acknowledge the territory that i'm in 36
territory
home to the kree peoples and uh great
homeland of the metis nation
i also want to acknowledge my ancestors
who are clearly here with me
[Music]
oh my god
son canada is so bad at being liberal
dude i know they can't handle covert
lockdowns they make this [ __ ] an
indigenous spokesperson how'd they find
they're scared of jordan peterson they
just can't do any of it right
do you know how they found out this year
associate professor was suspicious and
started doing some digging hayden and
that's when she came out with the i was
adopted by some people from the metis
nation or whatever you say uh and so i
was so close to them that they felt like
they were my real parents i was closer
to them than my real parents something
like that and then i think people found
out that [ __ ] wasn't even true i think
it's just all the things so that guy is
a real native american that called her
out because like that's native american
intuition yeah you're just just hanging
out with her like yo there's something
off with your spirit let me tell you
they're vibes people that don't have
intuition
it's native american that's a good point
that's a point counterpoint why so white
guy offers to buy your whole state for
five dollars and you're like yeah let's
do it
they got [ __ ] over in the deal that's
intuition you had an intuition you don't
want the intuition the boys were coming
they were about to lose everything
where's that intuition
where's the intuition i don't think
these people have intuition they made a
deal they're like all right yeah you can
have this land i'll give you this amount
of money for it they're like all right
bet and then they got they didn't hold
up the other side of the deal yeah we
did we gave them everything why do you
say we because i'm taking on all white
things
i'm not gonna be like these [ __ ]
cucks to claim non-binary so they have
to take remove all responsibilities
binary i am white binary
b-y-e yeah actually i'm not even both of
them shits i'm just men
you narry dog
out there just mono area
i am men i am i he
what is it
what is it called
he him yeah
yeah we got to bring back pronouns yeah
it's right yeah absolutely anyway yeah i
don't know we've probably uh
made fun of native americans in an
appropriate amount so far on this
podcast but um well listen it wouldn't
be nice if there was somebody trying to
help this group of people
somebody that was out there trying to
make sure that they were healthy and
they had all this the supplies they
needed to live a healthy life she's
taking her job away from a real native
american who's trying to do that ah i
agree with you but yeah i know i know
yeah but don't you just want the best
person to have the job this should be
complete meritocracy if you're saving
lives whoever's the best i don't give a
[ __ ] what color you are if you save the
most indigenous lives you got that [ __ ]
hundred percent the name of [ __ ]
would be like oh white people tried to
solve the problem before
no they didn't no you were the problem
they were trying to solve before
that's the issue they solved the problem
too well before honestly
not well enough if you thinking of their
point of view i mean but yeah
yeah i didn't really solve that problem
no problem eddie over here what problem
yeah you don't think that problem was
solved ain't even enough native
americans to be a chancellor of health
sounds like problem solved to me
yo right or wrong
interesting what about that professor
that found out though she was interested
in american neither hate ness [ __ ]
i think can't just accuse people of
being jewish right how do you know what
she is or is it you don't know there's
no rules anymore i'm native american
today but how do you know i'm native he
identifies as i identify as native
american
what is that
you don't look native american it
doesn't matter if i look native american
he's native new york isn't that not
native american i'm native american oh
this is actually native american land
that's a good point i'm native american
i'm iroquois
were they in new york yeah
of course they were [ __ ] iroquois
or the iroquois
virtual insanity right here
[Laughter]
no like whatever dude like anybody's
everything now there's no rules anymore
yeah yeah like stop it with rules you're
quite actually in new york of course
they're from new york i know all the new
tribes dude give me another i smashed a
girl there was cree once
you got creased
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah
yeah no but in all seriousness i did do
that and how was it was it good it was
phenomenal
i did it i saw that movie that uh
leonardo dicaprio was in
and um i needed one for myself yeah the
revenant right revving it yeah yeah and
your boy grabbed behind the knees
stirrups
gobble gobble
you know what i mean can we feast you
know we had to use every part of the
buffalo [ __ ] lose every like that but i
wasn't rotating because i wasn't on a
rotating chair but i just grabbed the
stirrups and it was gobble gobble tight
wounded
knees dude it was yeah it was great cree
cree
same tribe yeah how did that come up you
asked who
you asked her
girl yeah yeah of course
and she said she was crazy she said she
was greedy
mountain bear uh something what was her
name
it might have been her to be honest with
you i think it was that girl i think
catherine barrosa ate my ass
actually that's the saddest thing to
find out that the girl that ate my ass
catherine baroza
was actually not a true native american
that's [ __ ] up i know you were yo you
are but you've been betrayed i have been
betrayed you need to be made whole again
how can i be made whole get somebody in
that hole again
[Applause]